[Musique]
le roi arthur vient vous êtes de retour
et ça c'est vraiment une bonne nouvelle
pour nous tous un bien sûr mais surtout
pour le peuple breton qui arme a
commencé sérieusement tire la langue
c'est à dire c'est métaphorique petit il
tire pas les tirs allemands tous la
langue
sont au bout du rouleau bois
c'est par amitié pas c'est pas
littéralement un gros rouleau avec des
jambes camelot premier volet voilà
maintenant si vous ne sentez pas vous ne
sentez pas au cinéma le 21 juillet
arthur pendragon
un bien dont l'ont convaincu me disant
qu'on a plus vu son pif il et cannelle
fils pendragon le sait tous évidemment
qu'il est pas mort ça fait dix ans que
je vis en gros ça suffit mon dieu
comment sais pas je suis absolument pas
royer pas besoin de celui
là cela retrouver le jeu vous fait tous
pendre par les parties ah bon alors
c'est très constructif
la résistance ça vous dit quelque chose
allez
organiser ça pouvait être intéressant de
réaliser une rencontre avec les
représentants de la résistance vous
entendez quelque chose et at-il valette
une boîte on qui gagnent 10 ans vous
entendez quelque chose enfin quelque
chose de complètement informel c'est pas
possible d'être largué voilà
comment ça se passe est petite
résistance
bon vous faites deux cent pas sur le
chemin et vous monter la garde au cas où
quelqu'un approche approche son chemin
vous faites deux cent pas sur le chemin
et vous montez la gare et si la personne
qui approchent support on revient
non vous monter la garde
il y aurait moyen de réduire la voilure
sur la connerie
de fils pendragon est de retour abba qui
viennent
il faut tuer arthur vous savez pas faire
ça entraîner les troupes
les sièges
il faisait pas impensable
bah oui mais j'en prenais pas des
débiles qui j'entretenais des débiles
mais pas des débiles comme ça
qu'est ce que vous entendez exactement
par vous êtes de retour dès fois que
vous redevenir roi quoi oui oui basse et
c'est vrai que ça fait envie quoi voilà
maintenant si vous le sentez pas vous le
sentez pas